hi everyone today
jennifer and i are very excited to walk
you through the beyond core story from
google we want to walk you through what
google
how google started this journey how we
now enable customers to do it and how
you can get started in a crawl walk run
function
so let's get started my name is amitjani
and i'm a product manager here on the
google cloud team on the security team
focused on our xero trust tools called
beyondcore
and hi everyone i'm an engagement
manager within our google's professional
services arm
that's our delivery services i look
after our key us
insurance and payments accounts so um
the philosophy and notion of xero trust
is one that we're increasingly hearing
about in the industry
how do we explain to our customers what
xero trust is
and why it's so important yeah let's
take a look at that there's
there are a lot of great vendors out
there that are that are telling saying
that they're doing xero trust
and i think that if you look at what
google considers really the core
components that are required there are
four or five of them that are here
the first one is that every xero trust
solution really needs a strong identity
story
you need to be able to attest to the
user you'd be able to test the user's
metadata right what groups do they
belong to what roles do they have
i need to be able to start to build up
an understanding of the user's behavior
does the user normally do this at three
o'clock in the morning does the user
normally go to the site 50 times and
that's downloading a lot of files
it's really key to understand all those
attributes as part of the xero trust
story
the second part of this is really
understanding the context that's around
the user's request
in this case we're saying devices are a
key component of that is this a
corporate device is it a personal device
if it's a personal device is it running
an up-to-date os you know does it have
third-party solutions on there that we
consider really business critical
all that stuff needs to fit into the
model of understanding the context of
the request
along with location and time of day and
all these other things and session lists
the third and i think key component of
all this is what we call a rules engine
if you're anything like google you have
thousands of applications inside of your
enterprise and you need a way to deploy
rules against a thousand applications
without creating a thousand different
rules and so
this simplified rules engine is very key
to that story
and then i think lastly is this idea
that you should be able to deploy
all of your critical data whether it's
applications or vms or apis
all behind a proxy and the proxy in line
to the request
is able to look at the context every
single time a click is made to get to
access data
is this the right user are they still
coming from the right group are they
still coming from a device that's in
good state
do they still match the company policy
if not let's kill the request and if so
let's allow that request to go through
no matter where that application is go
it lives right whether it's on gcp on
another cloud or on-prem
doesn't matter so now that we've covered
the general components of xero trust
can you walk through how google
implements a xero trust model on google
cloud
google calls this beyond call where did
the name come from
and as a customer what are the typical
user journeys that you can see
yeah actually the journey started for us
about 10 years ago when we were
a it was an attempted attack on google
internal systems
what the lessons learned that came out
of that were that the network is really
an artificial bond of security once
you're in the network you have flat
access to everything that was a
terrifying
learning for us the other thing that was
really key is that we don't care
not only where what network you're on we
actually don't care about other
attributes what we really want to make
sure is are you the right user
coming from the right type of device
under the right circumstances
in order to get access to that
information and from that the idea was
you should be able to work beyond the
corporate walls and that got shortened
into beyond corp
we've taken all of the same tools and
all the same learnings and now we want
to expose them for customers to use as
well
so in that vein we've introduced four or
five key components that make the
beyondcorp journey possible for you and
your enterprise
the first one is what we call cloud
identity this doesn't necessarily mean
that we have to be the identity provider
we use octa use ping use azure id it
doesn't matter to us
all that matters to us is that you
federate all that user's information
to us so we can understand the metadata
around that user what groups they belong
to
and we can start to build up an
understanding of what is normal behavior
for all these different types of users
and we can use that to make dynamic
access decisions
the second part of this is really having
a ubiquitous endpoint we want to make
sure that you should be able to be
productive from any type of device
whether it's your corporate device or
byod or anything else
as long as we have an understanding of
what the security posture of that device
is and so for us we use chrome to do
that
the third one here and i said earlier
was this idea you should be able to
create
access rules and apply them at scale
across thousands and thousands of
different
endpoints and applications for us we
have a system called
access context manager that does exactly
that our best practices and our
learnings have shown
create tiers of access keep them very
simple less than ten
for google we've gotten down to five and
we said make them so
crystal clear that you can just apply
them to tiers of applications wherever
they happen to be so
classified applications get a high level
of rules applied to it
lunch menus and bus schedules and
everything else get lesser
uh non-confidential kinds of access
levels applied to it so you can access
from your personal mobile device
and again all of this stuff needs to be
able to
run through what we call our proxy in
our case it's called an identity where
proxy
this idea that you should be able to in
line again look at
all the context and all those requests
and still calculate on the fly
is this still a good request or not and
do it with near zero latency
and so for us that's our identity where
proxy those are the moving pieces around
the bianco
story so for customers wanting to start
implementing google's beyond corp
solution
it sounds like setting up an identity
aware proxy iap
is critical could you delve into iap as
well and also talk about what use cases
it suits and what it doesn't
yeah and i think you've nailed it the
iap or the identity proxy really is core
to a lot of this journey right
and so let's talk to what that is the
first thing is that it sits in front of
all of the different types of data and
applications that are out there or vms
or apis
and the basic idea is you should have to
make no changes to your code or to your
apis or anything else the proxy just
front loads all of that
the second part of it that i think is
really important is that this is a
globally distributed
managed service and so in fact this is
built on the same infrastructure google
uses to deploy
youtube or gmail and so you can
understand the kinds of latency
requirements that are built around the
proxy
and it also come built in then with
security so it does it takes care of all
the authentication all the context
checking for you so you don't need to
necessarily do that for your application
it also takes care of more
network-centric kinds of controls as
well it terminates tls for you
and it provides a globally scaled ddos
protection right again this is the same
front end we use
to protect our core businesses at google
from state sponsored ddos attacks and we
extend that to customers who are using
those applications behind iep
the other part of this is that the proxy
needs to be able to protect
any type of application or any type of
data whether that's web applications
whether that's ssh or tcp or rdp it
doesn't matter
it should all flow to the proxy where we
can go ahead and do all those context
checks before we forward the traffic on
and again the customers come to us all
the time and say i'm just starting my
cloud journey
my applications live everywhere the
proxy needs to be able to distribute and
take care of that for everybody
no matter where the application is
a common question that i hear from
customers is that users are accessing
applications from various devices
mobiles tablets desktops how do we
monitor the health of all those devices
at the user level yeah this is a common
problem we found when google was going
to the journey ourselves and now we're
hearing customers tell us the same thing
users have multiple devices and how do i
make sure that it's the right user using
the right device
and what are the attributes of that
device you know it's not uncommon today
for all of us to have
a corporate device a personal device at
home that we want to check email from
even our own devices or mobile devices
or devices given to us by work and all
the need to be able
we need to attest to the status of that
device before we allow access to systems
based on that device itself
and so to solve that problem google for
itself and then
now for customers has introduced
something called endpoint verification
endpoint verification simply sits inside
of a chrome browser on
any os mac windows linux chrome os or on
a mobile device outside of the chrome
browser
both ios and android and it collects
information about that device and it
sends
that information on every single request
made by the end user so if i started an
app and click around
both my user information my user session
data and the device data is sent on
those requests
and it helps you understand is this a
corporate device
is you know if it is and i know that
it's a safe i can allow this device to
do a lot more than for example byod
device i still want users to be
productive
they can still access gmail for example
or any of their email clients
we don't really want them to get into
too much of confidential data with
financial information
so you can make that kind of distinction
understanding the device posture
and then of course you can use that
device posture not just in accessing
applications but in accessing sas for
example with gmail
or for accessing apis you can say only
employees can be able to access public
apis that are that are out there
if they're coming from a device that i
trust so this information gets reused in
many different ways
so i mean this sounds great for
customers that are using google cloud's
platform what about customers that are
looking to integrate
iap with a non-google cloud platform is
this even possible
and are there still the security
benefits of beyondcorp
yeah in fact i would argue that many of
our customers today are doing exactly
this
right they're saying yes i'm starting my
cloud journey at either gcp
google cloud is one of my clouds or even
if it's the cloud i've chosen i still
have most of my workloads on prem
and i still i want a uniform and a
ubiquitous solution for all of my zero
trust models and so you can see all the
things we've talked about still apply
here
the first thing is as long as i
understand the endpoint status based on
endpoint verification and i know about
the user
all of that information is sent through
the google front end again whether we
can do all the analysis on the traffic
is the user doing normal behavior is it
coming from the right device has
anything changed since the last click
um and assuming everything goes right
and the proxy determines all the rules
are matched and nothing looks fishy
it just simply forwards the traffic back
to wherever the application happens to
live again whether it's on-prem or in
another cloud we have many customers
running in other clouds
and they use this solution to solve that
problem
i think it'll be helpful for our
customers to see this in action
let's go into the google cloud platform
console and start to walk through the
tactical steps that are needed to set
this
up yeah i like that idea in fact you
know this is a great opportunity to not
only do that but to walk through
sort of the baby steps that an
enterprise would need to start to
transition through to get to a zero
trust model you know the frequently
frequent thing i hear is i mean i buy
the zero trust beyond core story i
really understand what you're saying and
i'm sold
but how do i even get started i have 5
000 applications half of them are legacy
i have three different identity
providers
from from all these mergers and
acquisitions i think that's really the
crux and the first step of understanding
what's going on you need to understand
who are your users and what are the
devices that are accessing data right
whether they're yours or manage
somebody else and so i would argue that
any customer getting started on this
journey should spend a few weeks
understanding exactly that
so let's walk through what that looks
like and so in this example
i think it's really important that you
understand our back comes first and
understanding
who are in the groups that are assigned
there whether they're on google or
whether they're coming from octo or
azure it doesn't matter
the group membership needs to be present
and you'd be able to see is
are the right members part of the right
groups and are they here for example
so i can see this is the members of my
engineering team this is really critical
because you're going to later on to want
to create granular level access for
these sets of users and you're going to
want to use groups to do that
the other one is you're going to want to
get a sense of all the other users in
your organization is everybody here
that's supposed to get access right are
all my employees present in my
in my world all my 41 employees are here
but you want a deeper level
understanding of those users as well so
here i can see
in my enterprise i've got 41 employees
two recently left the company so they're
suspended
so i get a sense of all the people that
are there are they using second factor
this is really key
so you can see here alice is many of the
other employees aren't so that i can go
back and start to nag those employees
and say you really need to involve
enroll in second factor
and you can also get a sense of what are
the types of devices that are accessing
the data
again maybe they're in your corporate
fleet maybe they're not it doesn't
matter but you need to get a sense of
how that looks
in fact let's double click on what that
is the second part is
you should really understand the device
status and the device state for all
these employees here you can see my
device is running
an up-to-date version of mac os it's a
company device
you can save other byod devices that are
in here that's a concerning item that
are out of date right this is terrifying
to me
nobody should be accessing with 10.14.6
it's got a known bug in it
and so you can start to passively watch
all these trends over the course of x
weeks
and understand what does the fleet look
like what is the health of the
the users that are accessing my
infrastructure so i can use that to make
rules later on
so these rules how granular are these
security rules that we're setting up
yeah everything that you've seen every
all the attributes that you've seen plus
device attributes and location
attributes and time of day afterwards
can all be used to make that kind of
access rules and then you can apply them
against applications
so let's walk through now that i've
gotten a sense of
what my data set looks like who are the
users what are the groups that they're
accessing from
you know what are the devices let's get
a sense of how we can use exactly that
information
so you saw that i got a sense of my
device my my corporate fleet and i
understand what the kind of os is that
they're running and
are they corporate devices or not let's
uh codify this in rules so here you see
i've
already created three rules something
called secure device which can be a
corporate device
uh i have a contractors a tier so and
which device i don't control and i may
have byod again device i don't control
but i want to allow access
and you can also add geo rules and ip
rules and etc so here you can see
for company rules i can get a sense of
what are those policies i really insist
on screen lock i want to make sure that
i've marketed as a corporate device
and i'm going to make sure that it's
running the latest and greatest os
versions right for both windows mac and
chrome
because by company policy all these
devices should be updated
for contractors i don't necessarily
control that they may be a couple weeks
behind in upgrading
and i can get a sense of what that looks
like here uh the screen lock is enabled
it has to be approved by me
and for byod i just want to make sure
screen lock is enabled because
somebody's going to use that device to
check email i want to make sure that
they turn around
at starbucks for example that they don't
necessarily have that
machine swiped and so it can just access
that information
so that's that's in essence what you
would do with those rules
great and what are the types of
applications that make good starting
points for this journey
this is actually the core of what every
customer always asks me they say
you know i buy the vision yes i can go
and understand my corporate fleet
and my health of my devices but i really
don't even know where to start and so
some of the best practices we found from
our google experience what we tell our
customers and what we find where we have
success
is really do two things one is you can
start with any type of application but
starting with web applications
gives you the biggest bang for the value
a they're meant to be deployed on the
web
a b they have a subset of users who need
to access them so you can go ahead and
find out
uh is there a subset of hr contractors
for example we need to access this are
there contractors
outside of my org that i don't want to
give vpn access to but they can access
only one application
these are great sorts of proof of
concept applications that you can use
to really test out the zero trust value
right and again you can use all without
necessarily turning off the vpn
uh you can use it to test it out and
trust that you believe it and then then
you can go forward from there
so let's let's get a sense of what that
looks like you saw that i created the
rules previously
with access context manager now let's
come in and see how we can apply those
rules against applications
so again the identity where proxy comes
up first thing you see is that you don't
necessarily need to apply them against
just google cloud resources they can be
deployed against any resource
then here you can see a web application
this is in essence a dashboard
all the applications i have in my
environment you see some of them running
on gcp
i have some running on aws here and i
have some running on-prem and the idea
is it doesn't matter where they're
running you want to create a uniform
dashboard
the same is true by the way of rdp or
ssh or tcp sessions i have all these
resources located all over the place but
again i want to create uniform access
to those resources so let's actually
walk through what an example of that
looks like
the first one is i have a compensation
application it reveals financial
information about my employees and
other kinds of things i need to make
sure that only members of the hr
contracting group
should be allowed to access this so you
can see here i said hr contractors
can come in and access it but they can
only come in if they're accessing it
from
what we consider a secure device if you
remember we previously said what that
means
we want to make sure that this
information can never leak and the
devices have to be safe devices and so
now only
six members of the hr contracting group
coming in from corporate devices can see
that here's another example
we have a jira application and we want
to make sure all the employees inside
the company can see project statuses and
things like that
you can add that rule as well you can
say anybody who's an authenticated and
legitimate company user
meaning they come in from the right
domain should be able to access this
application
again but they need to be coming in from
at least a device that's running a
minimum security trust value here that
you know again screen lock is required
so they can access this application
and so you can and then of course you
can apply this at scale versus other
things
so let's get a sense of what that looks
like from an employee's point of view
here's bob
bob is an employee instead of logging
into a vpn and navigating to that
application
they fire up the browser they just enter
the url of the jira application and
they're logged in
there was just like you'd access gmail
or any type of sas application
internal systems are now easy to access
for employees but you're not you're
reducing the security posture in fact
you're strengthening it by saying
only these users from this time of day
should be able to access this
application
and so that's a really key component of
the zero truss story
okay so now that we've selected and
we've secured our key applications
is that enough actually i would argue
there's steps that are even more
important than anything we talked about
it and we have it here listed as step
four but i think it's
you could even think of this as step
zero in all of this right it's a
well-known fact that numerous studies
have been published that the biggest
attack
vector especially the most successful
attack vectors against your enterprise
are phished credentials and so i would
argue that session controls and second
factor are
really key to this entire story and so
we won't touch on session controls here
but it's really important to understand
if somebody's accessing highly
confidential data
maybe those sessions should be 10
minutes or 20 minutes or one hour they
shouldn't be 24 hour sessions
and the same will be true for second
factor here we'll show you what an
example of what that looks like so at
google we really really recommend
the second factor be there second factor
is better than no second factor of
course but we really push this idea of
fido keys so here you can see
for my applications i'm going to say i'm
enforcing second factor and it's going
to start in two weeks so i have time to
nag everybody
any new employee that joins has one week
to be able to register their their mfa
or get their key in the mail
if they're on the office and for us
we're saying security key is really the
best
story that you have right it doesn't
matter otp codes are being phished uh
there are many public examples of that
and so now that i've enabled for all the
applications in my enterprise
this idea that they require second
factor to get access to the applications
i can go one step further and create
granular levels of session control as
well
i can say for example that all
confidential data should have short
session lengths
my cafeteria menus are not confidential
data so it's okay if they don't require
a second factor
or it's a session last 24 hours i think
that's really step one
of this journey the second part of this
is actually
i think sort of more fundamental we've
talked so far about different types of
application
controlled by the data think about
applications of debt with confidential
information or vms that
that can shut down environments but
really
the key that's important here is that
you protect access to the production
systems themselves
think about this idea that somebody will
be able to log into your environment
and start shutting off vms that are
containers that are running really
important data
or that they can come into your identity
systems and just start to create
identities that you don't control
that now have backed our access to
everything and so we really say is that
the zero trust beyond corp model should
really extend to your cloud consoles
your administrative consoles
because that's really bright and butter
security to your company
okay so cyclops and networking are going
to be critical to implementing the
beyond club solution
to recap our next steps our key steps
it's critical to number one
understand who your users are and what
is the inventory of devices that are
being used
number two get granular with your
security by setting up context-aware
access level controls
number three identify your poc apps web
applications that have a common group of
users make a simple place to start
number four strength the user strengthen
user authentication through practices
like second factor authentication
and number five protect your internal
systems
yeah i think that that's a perfect
encapsulation of everything that we've
talked to so far it's a great place to
start this journey i know the journey to
zero trust seems overwhelming
but this really is a great list to say
let's at least crawl walk run let's
get started with the crawl phase these
are the great steps to do it in fact
there are numerous customers that have
already started this journey that are
publicly referenceable
there are thousands of google customers
that are now starting this journey
these are the public ones let me give
you a couple of examples to show you the
different types of use cases customers
have
last year airbnb was on stage with us
where they talked through this example
of they have contractors who are not
airbnb employees
accessing key key customer service
applications that are hosted on aws
they don't want to give them vpns they
don't want to build an authentication
system
this beyond corp story provided an easy
way for it to front those aws hosted
applications
for those sets of users another example
is home depot
home depot has 400 000 users you know
including the ones on the shop floor the
store floors
the idea should be that uh they're
seeing confidential inventory data right
this is core to what home depot does
we need to make sure that the devices
are accessing from locations that
they're accessing from
are relevant and stay safe right and as
as the employees that work in the store
are sometimes transient
we need to make sure that when they
leave working for this company that you
can shut down access for those users
and of course i meant it's important to
include google here google was the first
consumer of beyondcorp it's our
homegrown way of securing our systems
thanks for tuning in we hope that you've
learned a little bit more about google's
beyondcorp
and iap you now have the critical
building blocks that are needed to start
setting up this important security
service
and you've got product managers and
professional services
organization here to help you thanks